back right now lawmakers in carson city
are hard at work to finish up their
legislative session
eight news now is your only local
station on the ground there the i-team's
david charns joins us live now with more
david hey there sasha so we got about 30
hours left of this session a lot to get
to
and i'm joined here by a familiar face
here to eight news now viewers our eight
news now analyst
and politics and government editor at
the review journal steve sabelli see
we've got a lot to get to let's talk
about these two big issues left first
this mining tax we talked about to our
viewers here at five and six
the chances of this happening and what's
the need for it
yeah it doesn't look like much it's
pretty thin bill
here but it represents a lot of behind
the scenes discussion collaboration
compromise between a lot of the major
players
up here in carson city including the
nevada resort association
the nevada mining association and the
clark county education association
they've essentially compromised on a
package
that would see mining taxes diverted
directly to education funds
which is one of the largest changes to
education funding in the state in a long
time
and so the the chances of it passing i
think are very good because it's been
vetted by all of those industries and
plus legislative leaders are behind
right and this came about because of
obviously the pandemic we had a lag in
revenue and mining sort of
stepped up to the plate per se they had
this hearing that's going on now where
they said
we can pay for it and that rarely
happens when people say we can we'll get
tax
well and they were worried also that
there was an initiative petition that
might have been passed
that would have ended up taxing them
even more so this is
somewhat out of the goodness of their
heart but somewhat out of a desire not
to pay even more
next big issue here public option for
health insurance would create a
basically a government-run health
insurance if you wanted it
chances of this chances of this passing
likely or not
i think there is a good chance for
passing how it's going to be implemented
is a different story
they're going to do an actual actuarial
analysis
pardon me as the bill develops and goes
forward but i think because democrats
control both houses and the governor's
mansion it looks
like a very good chance that it's going
to pass it's already passed the senate
party line vote now to the assembly and
i think the same will happen there
all right steve sebelius thanks so much
and we'll keep you posted here on 8 news
now for
the next couple of hours of course
tomorrow crunch time lawmakers
they are required legally to end by the
end on may 31st which of course happens
to be memorial day
so we'll see what happens we're live in
carson city i'm david charns 8 news now
back to you sasha